[Music]
five minutes to six on your friday
morning so now that all those fancy new
flyover ramps are just about done
what's next let's go
centennial bowling
okay so that last flyover is supposed to
be done
by the end of the year that's the one
that's going to take you from the south
95
to go east on the 215 but there's a
whole bunch of other stuff yet to do in
the centennial bowl
so here's north and south 95 here's east
and west 215.
see this busy street running north and
south just west of the 95
that's oso blanca it's going away but
don't worry
it's going to be replaced by a new and
improved oso blanca
that's going to run under the 215 and
connect to centennial center drive on
the south
look for that work to start early next
year now all of this info
including a link to ndot's in-depth
project website
nevada us95nw.com that's all on our
website which is easy to remember
eightnewsnow.com you just click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com